full steam behind that's the focus of
tonight's angle
now before flying off to europe today
joe biden made a personal mission to
capitol hill to urge democrats to pass
his so-called infrastructure plan
i don't think it's hyperbole to say that
the white house that the house and
senate majorities and my presidency will
be determined by what happens in the
next week
i need you to help me he said
i need your votes probably did that
weird whisper thing well pelosi echoed
his plea telling her members
don't embarrass the president by voting
down the infrastructure bill
reportedly some members actually began
breaking out and chants not let's go
brandon but vote vote vote
but to what end
i have signaled for days that we simply
did not have the votes for the
bipartisan bill without the other bill
the build back better act our members
have been saying for months that these
two bills need to be it need to go
together
and that's what they're holding out for
in other words the grand madam of vote
whipping nancy pelosi was herself
whipped by the squad
the house speaker and the president
raised the stakes
and
it didn't work said
we want to make sure that when the
president lands in europe that people
know this is a functioning government
well that's not going to happen and so
that is a that is a loss
the president and i think in this case
too the speaker don't necessarily have
the leverage or the juice that maybe
they thought they did
ouch
with trump it was the art of the deal
but with biden and pelosi it's the art
of the fail
the democrats they have the house the
senate and the presidency
and yet they're the gang who can't shoot
straight
plus they've been wrong in their
predictions on every major issue and
their confidence in that afghan army and
their insistence that inflation will be
transitory and tonight will add to their
newest list of failed predictions that
passing these bills even paired down
will somehow be a lifeline to boosting
their popularity
now if anything with the spike in prices
coming and the dimming power of the
dollar biden's numbers are just going to
go lower
today the gdp numbers were released and
the news was as usual
under biden disappointing
the fact is even at a reduced price of
1.5 trillion dollars a staggering amount
still
it's still way more than we can afford
we are literally sticking our
grandchildren with these bills it is
immoral but the spin meisters and the
biden cabinet
oh they were all happy talk today i was
howling watching them
and it's like kind of trying to sell
sand in the mojave desert
the provisions that are in these two
bills oh my gosh so fantastic the things
that have been left out are not off
we're not dead on any of them we're
gonna live to fight another day we have
never seen this kind of investment in
our country and
people should be
feeling like man this is action and real
people are going to feel real impacts as
a result
oh yeah jennifer they're going to feel
real impacts all right on their wallets
any short-term stimulus from this bill
will be quickly diluted into
supercharged inflation
supposedly this is how they're going to
pretend to pay for all this
at 15 percent corporate minimum tax also
applies to foreign income for u.s based
multinationals a one percent excise on
corporate stock buybacks five percent
surtax on incomes above 10 million
additional 3 percent for incomes above
25 million 3.8 tax on active business
income for high earners
and well don't think for a second that
these punitive new taxes are actually
going to pay for the left spending plans
they never do
it's all part of an accounting game to
win over the gullible squishy
republicans and moderate democrats
and that's why it's important to look
beyond the price tag again it's a steep
price tag
these numbers are just easily
manipulated
because they game the cbo scoring
process what's actually more important
and far more disturbing
is what's in this bill here's a rundown
if you can read that little font there
it's a massive expansion of welfare
programs for your universal
pre-propagandic
to expanded health care subsidies even
when funding expires there'll be an
enormous resistance to doing away with
any of these plans
government programs never die remember
they just get fatter and more permanent
and 550 billion dollars ends up going to
climate change programs oh i'm sure
there's no there'll be no graft in there
no payoffs of the solyndra nature to
fojs
friends of joe
this is all just another wealth transfer
to left-wing activists they're going to
take your money and give it to their
greeniac friends
by the way included in the climate slush
fund is 320 billion dollars for
something called green energy and
electric vehicle subsidies though it's
not exactly clear that old jones even
knows how those confounded things work
we'll build out the first ever national
network of 500 000 electric vehicle
charging stations all across the country
you go all the way across america on a
single tank of gas figuratively speaking
it's not gas
you plug it in
sounds like someone forgot to plug him
in
there's also 110 billion dollars
earmarked for
growing supply chains
but just for renewable energy
do it in ways to grow the domestic
industries create good paying union jobs
address long-standing environmental
injustices as well we're going to get
off the sidelines on manufacturing solar
panels and wind farms and electric
vehicles with targeted manufacturing
credits sourcing the materials from here
in the united states
that's interesting because his own
administration
just blocked a copper and nickel mining
project in minnesota
a move that reuters describes as the
latest example of biden's plan to look
abroad
for our metal supplies to shore up
support with environmentalists and then
counter
to his private commitment to minors
american blue-collar workers are going
to get shafted once again
biden's big climate push
has zero to do with helping the american
people and everything to do with
appeasing the globalists at that un
climate summit coming up in glasgow in
just a couple of days it's all some part
of something this show has been warning
about for months
it's the great reset
now back in january the global elites
who gather at davos every year told us
where this was all heading
you don't want to go back to the status
quo
that you had before simply because it
was the status quo that got us here
capitalism as we know it is dead
this obsession that we have had with
maximizing profits for shareholders
alone has led to
incredible inequality and a planetary
emergency we must rebuild our
relationship with nature for the
survival of the peoples and our planet
was that hair pink or was that part of
the green energy project and that of
course means sacrificing your standard
of living and sacrificing your freedoms
and handing over more power to ecocrats
at the um
who's going to be the big beneficiary of
all this well the ccp will be
and they're going to be part of the
socialist one world web of regulations
and rules that undermine u.s sovereignty
china dominates the renewable energy
arena already including the rare earth
raw materials that we need for so many
of our products
those solar panels those wind turbines
that biden was bragging about they're
all going to be made overseas and once
again
we'll increase our dependence on a
murderous despotic regime have we
learned nothing from covid
no wonder the ccp is so adamant now
about climate action we must be
committed to green development as long
as we unite in our purposes and efforts
we will rise above the global climate
and environment challenges
even the translator is creepy sounding
now china has repeatedly embarrassed and
outmaneuvered the white house and now
they're doing the same thing on climate
because to the ccp it's like taking
candy from abiden
it's easy
even if biden passes his massive bill
all that climate spending will have zero
impact on future warming
china's gonna make sure that in the
meantime
it will be full throttle backward for
the united states we're going to go from
being an independent energy
self-sufficient first world country
we'll have a we'll had a reliable grid
to be almost a third world nation forced
to beg others for help
when wind and sunshine can't sustain us
meanwhile
our economy is just going to continue to
stagnate or even contract and americans
are going to see their savings and their
income
just eroded by the rising tide of
inflation your dollar is not going to go
as far
our debt and deficit will could further
explode
we're going to be worse off than we are
now
that's why democrats pinning their
re-election hopes on this bill oh my
gosh they're in for a big surprise
when americans go to the polls in a year
do democrats really believe that voters
are going to be pulling the lever
for a standard of living that's now
lower than it was a year or two earlier
i don't think so
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else